s'abonner
Je le fais déjà Turc Made
Je renouvelle toujours l'utilisation de tous
Je ne bois pas facilement à tout le monde, par exemple
Pourquoi est-ce que je boycotte les produits américains ?
Je ne vais pas mon jus natif
Je bois du jus d'orange quand tu en as
autant qu'il apportera au pays et à un peuple
Il y a tellement de dégâts que la marque française
une équipe produite ici
Il y a des marques françaises ici, toutes turques
les travailleurs travaillent pour les boycotter
Je ne pense pas que ce soit une solution.
c'est une décision émotionnelle prise de cette façon
Je n'approuve pas Oui, ça suffit la Turquie
nous sommes autosuffisants, nous n'avons pas besoin d'étrangers
bien
Ce Turc n'a d'amis que le Turc.
mais il n'y a rien de tel à obtenir
étrangers français
et nous boirons bien
ce spécialiste local de l'électroménager possède un petit
Je pense que nous devrions utiliser le nettoyage
boycott des seules marques françaises
exactement ce que l'on entend par
je ne comprends pas quelle marque française
Je ne le sais pas non plus, franchement, mais c'est très
à peu près autant que je sache
de nombreuses entreprises sont déjà aux mains des Français
Que sais-je, certaines marques de yaourt
Allez comme les marques alimentaires et le propriétaire
Nous ne connaissons même pas leurs noms
Comment quelque chose comme ça peut arriver quand tu ne sais pas
nous pouvons le faire je n'en ai aucune idée franchement
Maintenant ils menacent la Turquie
il est surtout israël
Par Allah, c'est Israël, nous devons manger et boire.
Donc, nous devons obtenir Israël France
nous obtenons ceux qui menacent de sortir
donc je suis d'accord parce que
surtout en tant que pays musulman
Et s'ils méprisaient les musulmans
bien